just uploaded a video to the internet
can't wait to go home see it it's real
good for those Netflix fans out there
who have yet to stumble onto any Miranda
sings videos what should they know
before they tune into haters back off oh
man I think I should just go into it
with an open mind I think if you go into
it expecting anything in particular you
might be disappointed because it is so
different from what I think anyone is
expecting from the show all the
characters in the show I had developed
four years prior to making the show so
it's all pulled from real things so I'm
hoping that people watching will find
relatable qualities within the
relationships sounds easy to me talk to
me about the process of going from
YouTube stars to now Netflix star I've
been doing YouTube for almost a decade
and that's what I've always known to
work on this Netflix show was a totally
different experience because we had a
huge team of people helping and you know
at first I was nervous about that but
then once I started working with them I
was like this is incredible I can't tell
you how magical it was the first day
where I was on set in the house to see
it in person was just mind-blowing
I definitely went home and I like cried
happy tears that night I was like I
can't believe this is happening it's
really cool
[Music]
you